[Music]
for
is
so
the in order to get ourselves in the
ballp part of discussion here is we have
to figure out what we're doing and what
we're not doing okay so this is C
hole and the
hole kanji denotes like cultivation
drilling it's probably the best
translation so I'm drilling
c
um you can't look up CQ in a dictionary
it's it's not going to work uh and it's
meaning it's really really old and by
circumstances quite
esoteric so rather than go through that
full history we'll just say it does not
mean
breath is it unrelated to breath no I
didn't say that but it does not mean
breath so you're not going to breathe
your way here in fact you could drill
cou and use C in the larger sense
while holding your
breath exhaling inhaling whistling
singing it doesn't matter what you're
doing with your
breath it does not mean
breath so you're drilling
Co to gain the skill of Co and what is
that
skill it is the Yang
variant of
internalizing
energy as a y variant it has particular
characteristics but none of those
characteristics are
antithetical to the yin VAR Varian of
internalizing energy so at a certain
point
the yin variant is not clearly
distinct from the yangong
variant the yin variant is
I why have a drill and not call it iy
hole you could have you could
have but in my
experience there is a passivity to
II it War
happens as a result of something not
happening so to cultivate
I is kind of
weird but I can't cultivate
C but in the cultivation of C the
cultivation of the young variant of
internalizing energy you're going to
have to do I cannot not
happen but there's another reason for
why you would have a c hole and not an
iy hole well the F first reason is you
you will have iole in the pohole right
and then the second reason is iy no iy
hole because uh it happens past
the but the third reason
is that from a pedagogical point of view
with like like what helps the beginner
move from no cou no internal skills to
having those skills it is much easier to
go through C than to try to go through I
okay
so that said what it what it's not it's
not
sparring it's not
self-defense it's not a wrist grab
defense
um it's not a
throw the fact that he is thrown is
irrelevant to the drug
okay um it's not a technique either all
it has it become a technique yes it has
has it become a throw yes it has has it
become some sort of wrist grab yes are
there people who go uh no one would grab
you and sit like that in front of you
view he just punch you see they're
working from a sparring point of view
this is all
degeneration all it happens
both inside iido and outside from
outside iido looking at
C in that sense what you're doing is
very akin to as an analogy is if you
want to let's say you have a marshall
concern and uh he knows from experience
it's better to be stronger than weaker
from a marshal
concern so he's going to work
out he's going to lift weights and he's
going to be very strong he's a very
strong
dude but that doesn't mean he can fight
so he develops that
skill and with that skill he goes on to
develop his martial
capacity life wise
CQ is not in itself a marshal
skill but once you understand KQ once
you understand II you have to go on if
you from a marshall point of view you
have to go on to figure out how to use
it you're not going to use it like this
I sit down here and he grabs one that
this is a
drill so as a drill or as a skill
development that I would later use
martially by developing myself martially
with technique with
strategy with experience just like
lifting if he's doing bench
press I don't come by and go that
bar does not hit
back that this is
this person does not understand
what a TR true Marshall concern is
okay the bar has an expected role in
order for him to develop himself
strengthwise for a bench press let's
say so too does
auk in koku home they have an expected
role okay their expected role is to
touch me at the
wrist and spinally displ me with their
own
C
projection while he's doing
that that will provide the energy that I
internalize let pass through my
body go down onto the ground my contact
point with a greater mass in this case
the
ground bounce off of the ground back
through my body and
into the center of his body not back
into his shoulders or into his hands
okay whether he falls or does not fall
is irrelevant what you should see is as
if uh you come over
here there'll be like a projecting Force
into the center from how he's sitting
now that's about where his uh humo is on
his Haka okay and it'll look like if
somebody grabbed him from the belt and
kind of pulled that thing out okay so
let's watch his
Center and uh you can go gradually but
slow and you can see that part right
there where this kind of caves around it
okay we'll do do it
again right there is what you want to
look
for so I'll show you some contrasting
things uh
contrasting uh diff so what I'm not
doing is I'm not trying to create a lean
in his body by
manipulating his line of gravity okay
I'm not trying to take this hand this
way lift up his elbow and then just lean
his line of gravity outside his Bas of
support So if you watch his Center and
it just kind of spills
out can you see that
okay um you can do the same arm
techniques you know I have a Yin arm out
here where I cut over the top and I have
a young arm over here can still have his
elbow up but something different happens
to a center so on this one he kind of
rolls out of his Bas of support and on
the other one Bo I push him out I
project his Center out of his
basis that
projecting that's indicative of C
okay that separating energy him from me
is indicative of
c and I key is a Yin variant so there's
no projection there's a drawing in and
there's no separation there is a
communion in that adhesion okay so for
example just to show it and get in the
conversation this goes into his center
right there into his Center or right
here is a I can use that I adhesion you
see that so as I'm drilling C boom HP
and I'll come right into the next
one a loose connection again I can
accelerate his energy into me with not
by getting out of the way but with that
same I adhesion so here I'm going to use
that adhesion here I could be on the
outside and use that
eny and then send it back out okay all
right let's keep keep going with more of
what it is and what it's not all
right go back to the idea that he has a
prescribed role his prescribed
role sets up the
drill I'll be the
UK when I
attempt to gain a CQ projection of his
Center you see of his
Center
and he does not let himself be
projected from the very beginning we
have a stablish a center to Center
relationship what would not be
that and just
here loose okay just loose that's it or
shoving my shoulders in
you that's only here
my C engagement starts as UK where you
have
it not by here and
shoving but generating the
initial relationship there it is right
there he's pushing into my Center I'm
pushing into his Center what he's going
to do now is let that energy pass
through him boom and then push it back
into my
Center to get it to
go watch what can
happen if I start changing my
Ru so I I didn't do it there's no
initial training drill the bar is not on
the
upright okay or I do start it and when I
feel it I now went limp again
it's loose
again so I have that
relationship and my goal is UK is to
keep that relationship so that
he can send that energy
down I
go I just look escape from that
relationship if you watch the energy
that he's projecting up to movement go
ahead do it slow the energy that's
coming back into my body right there I
will absorb in my
arms you see that okay now the bar on
the bench press all of a sudden got all
rubbery it's not working for my skill
okay so to set the drill
up you establish the center to Center
relationship that means my Center is in
my hands and my energy is going into his
Center down now he will feel that aim it
back into me and there is so to speak
the initial conflict that the ji Jitsu
will reconcile okay it will reconcile it
internally though boom
pop okay let us get there
good okay
so
one thing was already
said um and that is that when I project
back I don't project into your shoulders
I'm not project in here
okay so someone who might not have ever
experienced
this tries to figure it out with the
tools that they have okay and for
example if they are doing C you whole
and they're practicing a
throw this kind of
throw
or by extension what is that that's just
a manipulation of your
uh your frame let's say or your posture
such that your line of Gravity Falls
outside your basis support and then you
will tilt over
I
you all
right any any of those versions so you
know I come here do you see and then I
turn all of that is the same it is an
external
manipulation of her shape such that her
line of Gravity Falls outside her Bas of
support and she loses her balance which
she then recovers with a gold okay
um another external manipulation is the
one where I just push into your
shoulders so you have a job to do you
did not do your job there so I'll
correct you first you have to find my
Center find my Center okay got it and I
would say already you're you're already
in your shoulders when you do that one
okay but go ahead and do it and I'm not
supposed to do it back to
you so I'll use you a lot here okay okay
so the person's pushing at me and
someone trying to figure out what is
going on is going to think that because
she has her arm straight that I am just
pushing into her
shoulders okay but uh if we go if we go
a
while uh you'll
see well that one didn't go in her
shoulders clearly my hands were her
hands were way below her shoulders
okay
um another
one
is when I go to push so I'm not pushing
like this and you're not supposed to
push back like
that if I pick up the
energy you will never be able to do it
okay if you're doing shoulder toosh
shoulder push external manipulation Okay
so so we go and
I and I keep that pressure on she'll
never every time she pushes into my
shoulders on you going to do it do the
technique and it'll never happen you
see I'll show
[Music]
you the more he increases the pressure
the more he's really trying to get my
Center going do you get it the opposite
happens so if I'm doing it
internally the more he energy he gives
me to work
with the actual easier it is when you do
an external
manipulation the more energy you're
given to work with the less you can do
with it it just overpowers you okay so
uh he's going to get tired cuz he's
putting all that energy and you'll see
like let's say like medium energy you
can see look at how much movement that
was that's still a lot of
movement but he pushes
hard less movement he's really driving
and I can do less less every
[Music]
time do you understand that so that's
the distinction okay
um so we're going to pick it up now it's
some of you going to get shut down
because you're just here and you're just
trying to shove someone down
okay so Tristan was able to kind of shut
two of you down but I would I want I
want ngas to be shut down okay and only
the the ngas that can do
it they'll be moving less and doing it
drive drive
drive
okay and again you can see the
trajectory is in the center not in the
shoulders okay
[Music]
let's
Drive hard
[Music]
hi switch
rolls
okay
so
uh I'm now I'm looking at this thing and
I'm trying to figure out I've never felt
that uh and it's I would say in iido
it is more likely that you have not felt
these
skills you have you have in essence a
lot
of unsophisticated to
sophisticated external manipulation of
someone's equilibrium for the most part
makes up most
ikeo and then a whole lot of cultural
fiction that supports the
delusion that somebody of high
rank has these skills they they don't
they do not my teachers did not they
don't
simultaneously you have another
art that is connected historically to
the
founder that
in my opinion is doing something
radically different when they talk about
internal skills so dto you is doing
something totally
different for them they believe or they
posit or they
suggest that what they're doing is
different by which they mean
better so
yes there might be some Chinese
influences or there might be some uh um
coming to a different Solution on the
same
problem but there's an air that it's
better and I would say it's
not I would ignore completely what that
lineage is saying as far as internal
skills and stick with this stuff
okay there's a long history with many
more Arts that understand yin and
yangong internally not just
externally and understand it as just
generally described here a y separating
energy and a Yin communing
energy in that vein there are so many
countless Traditions that make way more
divisions way more categories stories um
to describe what is going on some get
very
poetic uh some get very esoteric and I
just to me it is irrelevant because none
of it helps you actually get these
skills and we will have to discuss
why all of those
things no matter how scientistic they
get today such as it's in your
fascia is all poetic they are all
upaya they are
Pointers trying to get somebody who has
no experience of it to experience it to
become sensitive enough to experience it
and distinguish it from what it's not so
so far as you guys were going we we
could see that many of you thought coku
is just sending energy back up the
shoulders and kind of taking advantage
that he had rigidity in his arms but
it's not that
okay so let us continue to look more uh
into what it is not okay so
um I described it and and here I'm
telling you how I'm describing it is
equally poetic meaning as
aaya it both points to what you're
trying to do but as aaya is also an
obstacle to what you want to try to do
okay which means it's both true and not
true so the poetic that I use is that
his energy is going to go down into my
body and down onto the ground that's the
imagery that you're using
Okay
um let's
see so some might look at this and go no
this is just a skeletal alignment and a
sound body mechanics okay so uh yet it
failed us when the guy push really hard
okay
so what I describe poetically is that
energy is going into me and going
down there's nothing in that that says I
need to have good skeletal Alignment
good posture or anything at all do you
do you understand okay so for example if
he's pushing here you you can look at
well that you have skeletal alignment
and uh you're just have sound body
mechanics okay but there's some problems
here my go ahead and keep pushing my arm
is
not uh rigid so this this would make
sense to a secular materialist but this
starts to not push really hard this
starts to not make sense okay and same
as I start going here this doesn't make
sense you got do different
things this doesn't make sense push this
does not make sense I have terrible
mechanics okay push terrible
mechanics moving back into position does
not make sense
likewise he's he's out here and he's
pushing if I can take the energy that's
coming forward and P it and and take it
off the straight Dory trajectory that
the the materialist
SE and aim it
down aim it
down then I can do it off to the side in
other words I don't have to go oh oh oh
he could be
out that same energy is here not like oh
distal end of the lever he should have
it weak deltoid this energy here is
going same place same exact place and
life if I want to move it's
loose but I can move back into him back
into
him you can't get
up you kind sit
down you see that it's not the skeletal
alignment so watch how many
times I don't actually have
skeletal alignment or mechanical
advantage with fulcrums and levers as
we're going
okay
uh we'll
go this one it should not be working
there's a lot of weight on
[Music]
there
another
one this is energy too what you see a
lot is this here is a mechanical
advantage you see so if I go here and I
brace myself he pushes and I'm bracing
here but this is
different this is different same thing
smash the arm
smash the arm smash it he's pushing it's
still going into the ground I don't need
my hand out there same thing I can stand
up go
push
push loose relax that energy is going
down and I can send it down and back up
so I'm not out
external trying to shove him down I'm
trying to figure
out how to get his
energy to no longer contest where it is
touching me and to pass through
me two
times in a Yang way in a Yin
way and then in a Yang way okay his
energy is coming in
where do I send it not into his
shoulders back into his
[Music]
body
okay let's try it on the shoulder press
okay chest
goes
head under her
shoulders put it in his
Center
better
so do you you feel that external push
when you push up his arms like that what
did we learn from the last segment when
you push up his arms like
that what if he's really pushing back at
you you're going to go bouncing off
[Music]
okay
try not to go up his
arms get your head back in
[Music]
place
so we've mentioned what you're not doing
and what you're doing is that energy
going in and back out but we are
understanding that as you Pi it's both
true and not
true okay but how do you do it that's
another question okay and this part is
important because this is what
makes skill at I and
C Paramount to the identity of the art
so there are three marks of the art this
is these are the defining
marks out outside of these three it
anything can be and everything can
be the first Mark is Divine
communion
however whatever that means to
you but it has to mean this the a
a a Reconciliation of the subject object
dichotomy in the experiencing of life so
what you want to do the probably the
easiest way of understanding that and it
is not easy is to just allow the
religious historical record to tell you
what that
is and when you look at what that is
from old sensei's traditions to St John
of the
cross it is that
passive receiving of the Divine it is
Grace you don't do it you undo you and
it happens to you
it is done through
Grace so oh since I did these possession
rituals that that's what they are you
learn how to in our discourse
deconstruct the ego
tripartite and the second mind aspect
starts to function passively that is
divine
[Music]
communion well that's what you're doing
when I let ual energy into me I'm not
obstructing it I'm letting it into
me these two things here are
concentric in their
mechanisms but they're
distinct but they're the
same structurally how they function is
the same I get out of the way
and this energy is allowed to pass
through me both
ways if we look at what stops Divine
communion well I defined it it's your
ego
tripartite but the ego tripartite
functions with and
through
fear so here you are and we're doing the
second Mark of iido the I C you the
internal
aspects why you can't do them is you are
in a state of abiding in
fear and
fear keeps a separation keeps you
separate from God keeps you separate
from the Divine keeps you separate
subject and object
dichotomy when we say iido is love we
mean that separation is no longer my
experience we don't just mean it
psychologically we mean it energetically
we mean it
experientially we mean it in all
ways so if I come to this thing and you
pay
attention when he goes to do his role do
you see
that if you can't observe and gain a
subtle skill and I identifying what
you're feeling and thinking at that
point you will see that you are in a
dichotomist experience right now he is
pushing on
me and in that dichotomy you don't want
this to happen because you're starting
to feel in
cave and at the speed of life you start
pushing back on him as opposed to I can
keep my hands here and change this
relationship
entirely do you feel that difference so
here I'm going to change it
boom and you can see I'm free
again here not free again holy cow if I
move any he's going to start tipping me
over whoa whoa whoa you can do it okay
here we are I'm going to let it go
again got and I'm free again to
move and that is
why the founder is right at a certain
point your Marshal
concern it just gets in the way because
your Marshal concern is fear-based and
dichotomous
based and that is why you going do you
want to learn my keto just do c you ho
every technique is C youho you can make
it
such not me throwing
him not me wondering will a real guy
grab you their hands like that I don't
think
so okay so as I'm doing this
skill you cannot leave the spiritual
component out because it's a spiritual
thing I got to not feel threat threed by
him and the second I'm not threatened by
him that energy passes through me and I
can move everything
else but for where I am grounding it do
do you understand
so here terrible mechanics terrible
mechanics I can just release and it goes
through me goes through me and I'm free
again terrible mechanic and whatever I
want to do I I want to go into his
Center so I go into his
Center I want him to go around me so I
have him go around
me I want him to go to that corner or I
have him go to that
corner this corner over here we go to
that corner this corner over here go to
that I want to go straight
back okay
so how do you do
it this is
my I I don't I'm not a fan of all the
Poetics take the dragon G and move it to
the Jupiter orbit
no
okay you want to
practice a releasing skill okay and you
have to start from a place of tension
first okay I I think of it as like a a
game where or
Jenga you're going to take tiles
away that are not necessary for the
tower to maintain its
Integrity so first you have all the
tiles in place nice t
body okay and then he's going to start
to release
things don't let your elbows go back too
far unless you have my Center
okay releas see what other tiles you can
take
out and your
skill you can say is where I only need
one
tile
and everything else can go to CB it's
not important okay so he's pushing and I
could be pretty
relaxed and as you get more skilled you
will uh be even more
relaxed and less
movement and you can see H what I feel
is like oh he got me there it triggered
my push on him and so that's my skill to
releasing
not releasing it this way you could but
internal release it relax
it he'll push it'll trigger ah
release you'll also have a separating
mind when you feel the throw got him
that will take away your internal skills
do not be concerned with the throw
either just the feeling of it going
through your
body all points of contention let them
go whatever is not involved with the
structure Let It Go
release
okay so you can think of kokle then as a
releasing skill development drill that
is concentric with the releasing
skill necessary to receive the grace of
divine Community okay let's try
[Music]
it feel the desire to throw him that's a
fear-based that's a
separating
psyche just feel the energy go through
you come out of you that's all you
feel release and move kind move just
don't don't push on
him
[Music]
for
there are yogic understandings behind
all this and that's just to again
simplify the historical
record we can say in modern terms there
is no division between the mind and the
body and that is why certain thoughts
generate certain bodies it generate
certain experiences of the world okay so
um in order for example if I have a fear
state if I get pushed by my ego
tripartite into a dichotomous
relationship with him that's where you
try to push on you try to push on him
but we re we remember that if he's
driving with Coq you're going to get get
overpowered every single
time well if we look at it
yogic that fear state made me go into my
shoulders I did not keep my shoulders
out of it I did not
keep let's just say
Center or better said I did not keep the
formation or the organization of my body
such that his energy passed through me
and went to the
ground instead he goes to push and I
locked it up in my shoulders which got
over power okay so you could say that
fear
States not only
block the receiving of energy or the
receiving of GRA
but they create
blockages at my
limbs they become separated from my body
as a whole and I become over dependent
on
them this is important because once you
understand that you understand that
UK is not at all a bar
UK is doing the same exact training that
I am doing so the energy that he first
gives right once it comes bouncing back
into me I receive that
energy it
like grace of God comes into my body and
I receive it as opposed to entering into
the fierce State take it a little bit
more and you'll feel like see he's got
me what the afraid UK will do is regain
control do you see that and they will
take that energy out of their Center go
a little more and put it in their
arms this is a very inefficient way of
doing Cy
hole but it will lead to
other things that you can gain from okay
so you brought that up that I have a
hard time I think you use the word
connecting with the UK who's disengaging
it's true okay but from this point of
view this UK is no longer
training so for example the same mass as
I project into
him he comes back I have that same
organization in my body it's the exact
same thing just I received
it the
afraid who disconnects and puts it in
their
shoulders same thing here I feel it in
my T my shoulders
again so now I'm not
training but what you can do is and it
is more difficult as the skilled uh nag
is it makes what you're trying to work
on harder to to achieve so it increases
your skill in it okay so she's pushing
and she you can see already she's
there's nothing in her arms here so what
I have to do is find her body and this
elbow do you see how that elbow is
starting to go in
I'll show you you're going to have to
come closer to see all this over
here and you can see from here so I want
to identify the problem so there's no
push here do you feel that you're not
displacing me at all okay which is
fine and now I'm going to get I'm going
to go into where I can still get her
Center so here I am there it was did you
feel right there I am pay feel for it
okay and then watch what you do this
elbow right here this elbow you're
starting to go around my energy you see
that okay so I go there it is right
there and then I'll move and you're
going around my you're feeling that
energy right there you see that and you
going around the energy okay all I have
to do and this takes us to the third
Mark of like
is
Takami so same
thing all of this I just do
spontaneously every time she's uh moving
I just keep moving with her to keep the
same Center connection okay when I
have a good barbell he establishes the
center connection I go in and down and
out and he keeps the center
connection here my barbell kind of wigs
out on
me when does it wig out pay attention in
other words it's not wigging out here
you're you're in my center right now do
you feel
that there it is right here this is all
Loosey Goosey okay why did it do it
there who can
guess why did it not do it here push why
ises it fine here well balanced you're
well balanced do you see that but the
second I go here there there's that
Mushi you see the shock absorption of
her elbows why CU now you're off balance
so what kind of emotional state are you
in panic a panic right fear it's a fear
State and so now she's not in her Center
okay but for me I will just
keep constantly adjusting as she's doing
that and refining her Center through
what she's doing can you see that so you
see how she still got projected out it's
not at the end that I go here and I
go I'll keep working every time she
counters
counters and I keep going into her
Center keep going into her Center can
you see that but if you pay attention
she constantly disengages her Center
folds her elbows opens her shoulders
lets her wrist go but it doesn't matter
at some way I'm going to find her
Center here we go
[Music]
girl you see all the little adjustments
okay can you feel that all right can you
feel where you try to let out the air
you're trying to take energy off okay so
the downside for you though is you're
wasting half of your training so I would
say
[Music]
this and again you have to remember
you're doing a
drill the more
throwable or the more projectable UK is
going to be the more projecting nogget
they understand the body mechanics they
understand the Fearless State they can
do it back they're not wasting 50% of
their training time okay but if I get a
UK who keeps coming out because they
keep going into a fierce State then I
will use them to work on the third mark
of aido which is that
Takami I I don't need her to push on me
it's just koku as a
drill has them push
as you work later with this skill you
should always find someone Center no
matter where you
touch their Mass
itself and its place on our
gravitational plane is enough energy
that you send it internally as we just
described here both in and down and out
and okay you don't need that extra push
and lock out
but it is a harder skill okay because it
requires that constant
[Music]
adaptation Let's uh let's do this and
that's where the game comes in remember
the the other game okay so the game
which I'm not calling
khole is uh he is trying to touch my
chest and he's trying to get out of my
counters you see
so in that way like the scaredy UK he
will disengage from me and try to get
himself free and I will have to be
required to all these disengagements to
still find his Center through the
disengagements okay as opposed to what
is what does this sometimes look like
his people are here like
this you got it so I'm here
[Music]
oh
and again people will look at it and go
why can't he get off he's trying to get
off he's trying to get off it's a
combination of uh here I followed
him so he got so limp I just followed
him but right here is an I key do you
feel that you see there's an adion right
here so you're like why can't he go down
cuz the the I adhesion is there it's
starting to take his
balance so he won't go down he'll do
something else he feels that you see and
where I
can't uh here I don't know that feels
pretty good I might not do anything you
see in other words I kind of got a
little bit there but if necessary I'll
come back on the
inside you see and then this hand has a
CQ so he will so you see I have his
mouth so he'll try to get himself free
of that you see and again it's still
there if we pay attention do you see
it's still there so he'll try to take it
off and I followed again it is back
again that's no different a skill than
when the SC that you get is trying to
bleed off energy into their Cent okay so
let's play the game for a little
bit
so a lot of it is in your shoulders
right
so do you feel how you're always
behind
Okay that's where the adhesion comes in
and that's where you have to do it on
the ukis side so you have 100 % training
time not 50% training
[Music]
time
so right at touch you can be in her
Center you don't have to wait for her to
try to touch your chest right right when
you touch her get in her Center she'll
try to counter by freeing her
Center in her body she'll counter
so rain try to figure out her favorite
moves she likes she likes to control the
biceps okay you got for your
biceps this is not poke you
[Music]
ho
you see how she gets your biceps every
time okay now again if she has a knife
in her hand you're just pushing her
biceps right you're it's not really a it
kind of wins the drill but not really
the
[Music]
skill it's very slippery do you feel
that so the idea he is
missing okay so uh if you look at the
historical
record of let's
keep Divine communion that's the
historical record of divine Community is
not a common
experience statistically it is an
uncommon experience is does everyone
have the potential yes they do does
every everyone who is seeking to achieve
it
know
likewise as the internal aspects koku
and II are just
concentric
manifestations of divine
communion if you look at the historical
record does across the
Traditions is it a great number of
people who can do it no no it's
not
is it guaranteed that everyone who puts
themsel on the path is going to achieve
those skills no it's not they tell you
it's not the
case is it possible for everyone yes it
is but if you understand it in
terms that I described
here we can say it's only as possible as
we can cease existing in a fear
State and now you
know not only is it not possible for
everyone but at certain times and under
certain
conditions even someone who could do it
under other conditions and at other
times might not be able to do it here
and
now
this is important because to
me often times trying to do
it is just another fear State and gets
in the
way and you can't do
it so you're trying to get that that
person not to touch your chest and all
of that trying is all fear and and now
you're just tense in your shoulders
there's no adhesion it's very slippery
and you're constantly following someone
which means you're reactionary but
there's no chance you're going to get it
it's a matter of time only before they
get
[Music]
it and this is
why as aido
Kona can be considered just just coku
hole in general it's all coku
ho and that kokuo is about developing a
particular
skill or a particular Body Mind
organization than any Marshal
concern has to include elements outside
of
kona you don't you don't fight with Kor
was
[Music]
though when you're doing your couo
you're not training to fight you're
training a skill
set that could be used
martially but you have to go on and
figure out how to use that skill set
Martian just like
[Music]
as I mentioned earlier if you understand
that you can liberate
yourself
from the incessant message of
self-defense and of someone attacking
you and and you stopping
them or you gaining victory over them
because you threw
them and
instead instead of
self-defense it's self
[Music]
relase so I'm not trying to throw him
I'm not trying to stop him from touching
my
chest if you pay attention every time
you you you you try to stop them before
that micro spark from a stone timing
before that you already were in that
state of fear that this bad thing was
going to
happen and then you got into your
shoulders and you just started bracing
on
them and in the game depending on the
UK's nature they either overpowered you
or they just slipped around you and
touched your
chest every time that that thing
happened that process
happened fear
dichotomy limb
isolation overpowered or too slow not
adhering enough can't stay up with
them
so as we now look at ourselves and make
a problem out of our effort effort to
achieve
something even as Noble as self-defense
or even as Noble as I want Divine
[Music]
communion but understand that that's
what is exactly stopping me from getting
it then we can in some way
hopefully reorient ourselves in our
training and then maybe again not
guaranteed
maybe we can reconcile
fear and receive
Grace there's no
guarantee but all that said you are much
better living a
life where you've made a problem of fear
and you have a practice wherein you try
to reconcile fear and you Aspire and
Orient yourselves towards reing
receiving Grace then if you been watch
Netflix and get all social justice out
and try to have a job that gives you
meaning and use your
soulmate to bring you meaning and all
that secular materialist
it's it should be a no-brainer
now the culture is not
working we're going mentally
ill we're spiritually
[Music]
bankrupt we need to return to these
paths okay so yes you're going to
struggle with tense relax tense relax
tense
relax but even tense relax tense relax
tense relax so in other
words you're like he's pushing and
you're and then you go relax and you
that could yeah that's not it that's not
it but this desire or let's say the
possibility of fluctuating between tense
relax it all comes from the same state
of being it all comes from a fear state
it all comes from a self attachment
State I just I know it sounds weird but
all I do is
stick and it looks like he can touch it
but he knows the more he pushes it goes
into his
body and on I know that the more I relax
the more it goes into his body as
opposed to I start putting in my
shoulder now it's just stronger stronger
and he's starting to slip do you feel
how you're
slipping so you can get very frustrated
you're like I don't know what to do that
is the
door that is the door you want to walk
through that sounds crazy but if you
look at the historical record tradition
after tradition has told you finally you
found the door finally you got here now
walk through the door stop knowing so
much Start abiding in I don't know what
to
do okay so you can't go 10
release okay stop all of those stop both
of them don't do those don't do those
well I don't know what to do
good good your problem was you knew what
to do
[Music]
okay